um dia entre nós e as palavras amor e
ódio quase guerra noite dia 11 se trevas
bom data e mal dava alegria e tristeza
na saúde e doença beleza e fiel da
cunham e solidão sonho e pesadelo
justiça e justiça
entre nós e as palavras
a viagem leva o céu e viaja leva o
inferno com palavras de aliciamento e
aceitação crescente de aceitação
esperançosa e escravização camuflada sob
a capa de negócio que não passa de uma
manipulação meia tcheco
entre nós e as palavras ao outro que é
sujeito e um outro que é o objeto a
dignidade respeitada e dignidade
aprovada
entre nós e as palavras a mulheres
homens crianças e jovens transformados
em objetos de desejo de trabalho forçado
transformados em campo bom
pior gaúcho
entre nós e as palavras há vítimas e
carrascos a vítimas libertadores
entre nós e as palavras ao ladrões dos
sonhos com trajes vai feitores a
denúncia e indiferença à justiça nem
sempre ativa
entre o norte e as palavras a tráfico de
pessoas
há tráfego de pessoas
segundo as nações unidas
todos os anos cerca de dois milhões e
mais suas são vítimas de tráfico
os países da união européia ratificaram
o protocolo de palermo que entrou em
vigor em 2003 ea partir daí criaram
planos a nível nacional e transnacional
e cujos objetivos são prevenir e
combater o tráfico de pessoas prestando
uma atenção especial às mulheres e
crianças proteger e ajudar as vítimas
disse tráfico respeitando plenamente os
seus direitos humanos promover a
cooperação entre estados membros de
forma a atingir esses objetivos
este protocol diz que às pressas ao
tráfico de pessoas significa o
recrutamento o transporte é
transferência o alojamento ou
acolhimento de pessoas recorrendo à
ameaça ou uso de força ou outras formas
de coação ao rapto a flauta ou engano ao
uso de autorizado ou a situação do fundo
da habilidade ou a entrega ea aceitação
de pagamentos de benefícios para obter o
consentimento de uma pessoa que tem
autoridade sobre outra
prefiro envia exploração
apesar da legislação é entre lan 2013 a
comissão europeia reconheceu que se de
um aumento significativo de vítimas de
tráfico dentro da união européia e
recomenda aos países membros a aplicação
mais rápido possível da legislação
europeia de luta contra o tráfico é
ameaçando aplicar sanções aos países que
não adotarem lei é legislação em
portugal data de 2007 e tem sido
utilizada neste momento vai já no seu
plano de combate ao tráfico de pessoas e
em 2008 foi criado o observatório de
tráfico de seres humanos cuja emissão e
produzir
procure e tratá e disseminar informação
e conhecimento sobre tráfico de seres
humanos e outras formas de violência de
gênero reclamação com a coordenação do
plano nacional contra o tráfico de
pessoas
apesar dos esforços desenvolvidos
o tráfico de pessoas primeiro s
em muitas de suas dimensões como
fenómeno oculto cujas dinâmicas e
elementos identificadores merece uma
análise profunda e continuada
apesar da existência de legislação é
condenação do traficante é quase nula
praticamente em todos os países
a detenção dos suspeitos traficantes têm
conduzido somente é penas por violência
doméstica no círio raptos unificação
documentos sobre a questão do rendimento
que se traduzem normalmente em multas o
que ele é e remete para o fundo da
gaveta o tráfico enquanto tal
isso acontece porque
aqui aponta alguns fatores que promovem
o tráfico é humano é falta de
oportunidades contexto local de
discriminação para determinados grupos
ego uso do poder
falta do live eficaz quanto o tráfico o
problema de definição a quem pensa que o
fato definição e que que o protocol que
eu tô alemão definiu não está
suficientemente e lúcida ativa é
perfeitamente porque a forma como está
escrita pode de fato os traficantes
suspeitos traficantes dizer é que se
trata apenas de coisas locais e portanto
a multa paga depois ainda quem aponta é
a idolatria do dinheiro assim o status
quo e acusação é o problema é que sendo
gritante parece ter contrapartidas
economicamente apreciava as deixa a
deslizar a resolução para mais tarde
é o tráfico de pessoas
faz mais dinheiro do que é troca é isto
em todo mundo é porque enquanto a droga
é esgota ventos estão se vendo uma vez o
tráfico de pessoas está sempre a fazer
dinheiro podem circular é vários sítios
e portanto de fato num montante de
dinheiro possa traficantes é de tal
maneira que o que eu seu risco com as
multas porque as multas é uma coisa
banheiro e aparelhos
há quem aponte é própria definição como
eu já disse que o tráfico de pessoas
porque apresenta exações que definição
apresenta e recrutamento o transporte é
transferência o alojamento ou
acolhimento de pessoas
isto não é crime do tráfico
em si
claro que depois da inscrição dje
recorrendo a ameaças uso de força mas
isso também pode não ser identificado
com o trio tráfico de pessoas
isso pode ser um outro crime que não o
tráfico de pessoas turca
só no final da sua missão é que nós
identificamos o tráfico é que lhes é
aceitar só o primeiro benefício para
obter consentimento de uma pessoa que
tem autoridade sobre o pérola fiz de
expressão é mesmo só no final
ora essas outras ações todas que estão
no início da definição os tribunais
podem não se fixado né no último quarto
para fins de exploração
portanto é algumas dessas ações em si
mesmas não são crime embora possam ser
identificados como locais os mais
utilizados também não são
necessariamente ligados ao tráfico para
a ação ser conhecida crime de tráfico
humano e é preciso fazer a prova do
objetivo que na conjuntura atual e nem
sempre é fácil
direi mesmo é extremamente difícil
porque preciso que a pessoa traficada
possa provar que aquela pessoa é tri
ficou fora é pessoa traficada está no
estado de tal é fragilizada que ela não
tem coragem para enfrentar um tribunal
ele dizia de fato eu fui crucificada
portanto o traficante passa é apenas é
ter uma pena de multa mais nada
agora há quem faça uma outra leitura
no fundo e é digamos é ela é idolatria
do dinheiro é ter 1989 o mundo estava
dividido erro maso duas potências
governavam o mundo é oeste bola e leste
o colunismo o norte era do ricos
o sul era dos pobres para emigrar é não
era um não eram precisos garante paz é
partir dos anos 90 com a queda do muro
de berlim
emerge
mais forte ainda é filosofia do dólar é
inimiga de sal começa a exigir
documentos vistos suporte econômico no
país de destino contratos de trabalho
contratos de trabalho a origem de 500
pagamentos condições condições condições
condições e da atualização de informação
cultura comércio transportes petizes
valor 60
o mundo perde a referência do norte e
sudoeste e oeste riqueza circula por
todos os continentes mas mês após uma
minoria 10% apenas enquanto a mobilidade
aumenta muito o ritmo
nesta conjuntura
quem tem recursos econômicos 10 por
cento da população tem excesso é tudo o
estilo de vida que ia pra fazer rir é
quem não tem esse poder econômico o
traficante ofereça quer sair da pobreza
em vídeos que eles e ir e quer de
encontrar uma vida mais desafogada cash
evoluir no com sua eu sou fresca
eu tenho levo para um país onde tudo
isso é possível
vejam
antes viam exposição é feita entre povos
os povos vencidos sobre os povos
olha os povos vencedores sobre os povos
conhecidos expressão era feito assim
neste momento a exploração é
individualizada
somos nós indivíduos por outro indivíduo
ou indivíduo que podem explorar os que
podem verificar os para ter cenário que
fazer o que posso fazer
o que fazer perante este flagelo frente
é escravidão dos tempos de hoje
quer dizer que posso ir fazer no mínimo
se utilizar prevenir e denunciar apoiar
as vítimas porque é urgente é mesmo
muito gente restituir a vida é quem dela
foi roubada entre nós e as palavras a
urgência de dizer não ao tráfico de
pessoas
só pessoa minuto
é a foto minuto apronto
tá muito obrigado